[Musik]
hey leute und willkommen bei einem red
star tutorial heute trage ich den skin
von travis und ich zeige euch wie man
einen automatischen dispenser baut viel
spaß so und hier befinden wir uns nun in
der tutorials welt die ich mir mal ganz
kurz hier generiert habe das geht ja mit
dem neue mit der neuen version dass man
damit einfach solche flachen welten
erstellen kann und das erste was ihr
denkt ist bestimmt war es luca und
redstone das geht überhaupt nicht klar
ich weiß eigentlich kann ich das doch
überhaupt nicht aber das habe ich so ein
ähnliches tutorial hab ich gesehen und
ich habe selber ein bisschen näher dran
rum gespielt und ich konzept ein
bisschen einfacher bauen und ich zeige
euch mal ganz kurz wie das nachher
aussehen soll und zwar wenn wir auf den
schalter drücken kommt nacheinander ganz
ganz viele items daraus die kann mir so
alle einsammeln gedrückt wieder auf den
schalter und es hört auf also ich dich
mal ganz kurz wieder da rein
ich habe einfach diamanten reingepackt
wir sehen hier einfach eine ganz normale
wand mit einem dispenser da hinten ist
ein schalter den habe ich an gemacht
dann habe ich ein paar repeater hin
gepackt ich aber ein bisschen verzögert
habe so dass das signal passend ankommt
und zwar hier und pisten bergmann hoch
und runter und immer wenn also das hier
ist eine ur nennt man das glaube ich
glock hat der engländer das genannt und
wenn man diesen block dann immer hoch
und runter und dadurch wird dieses rats
tonsignal immer aktiviert und
deaktiviert wodurch dann der dispenser
ein paar items or auspackt also ich
versuche das mal ganz kurz für euch
nachzubauen damit ihr seht wie das
ungefähr geht
so könnt ihr das auch ganz gut in eine
wand einbauen einfach und dahinter müsst
ihr dann einfach ein bisschen platz
haben also baut einfach eine wand
material ist egal dass dann dispenser
mitte da baut er ein schalter hier packt
ihr einen abbau tieren button hin
hier packt den schalter dran den macht
ihr aber an dann fällt schon das erste
ding raus ich hatte ja schon mal was
rein warte ich zeige euch das mal wenn
ich den je mehr an pak und anmache steht
ihr fällt schon der erste die haben dann
draußen ist jetzt noch ein bisschen
unspektakulär aber was schon etwas
cooler als wenn ihr hier ein restaurant
legt weg macht immer wenn hier sich
etwas verändert auf dem blog kommt ein
item raus gehüpft allerdings können wir
nicht die ganze zeit gegen die sollen
hier vorstellen der das immer an und
ausmacht sondern dafür haben wir hier
diese blöcke und das ganze hinter der
geschichte also hinter diesen ganzen
dingen
ich setze einfach hier im blog der die
blöcke sind relativ egal die könnt ihr
auch so verändern wie ihr das wollt
wir setzen hier einen repeater hin den
lassen wir einfach dass die tiere ein
bisschen komisch aus aber das ist die
erste stufe das muss ich am texture pack
noch ein bisschen verändern also das ist
eins zwei drei und vier
ihr lasst ihn einfach auf 1 danach wie
ihr seht bauen wir hier so was machen
den unteren wegpacken hier oben gar
nichts drauf sondern eine torchance
das war keine torchance das braucht
keine touch so hier packen wir dazu mein
restaurant hin und dann hier wieder ein
repeater falsche seite ja ein repeater
so den repeater packen wir auf die
dritte stufe ganz einfach also nicht auf
die allerletzte sondern auf die dritte
und hier packen wir nun wieder einen
ganz normalen block hin und hier darauf
komplett sondern dieses redstone wird
einerseits gepaart durch diesen repeater
aber auch durch diese redstone fackel
und wir wahrscheinlich noch wissen
müssen wir es hinkriegen dass das noch
in diamant wir müssen das hinkriegen
dass hier unten immer ein letzter
aktiviert und deaktiviert
beziehungsweise hingesetzt und wieder
abgesetzt wird
und dazu kommen wir jetzt mal wir würden
uns nämlich hier runter und wir würden
uns hier drei blöcke runter und da
setzen wir einen pisten hin
darauf könnt ihr einen block bauen wie
ihr wollt ich nehme da jetzt einfach mal
glas einfach damit ihr sehen könnt
und darauf könnt ihr nun sand tun ihr
könnt darauf auch gremmel tun sonst habe
ich gerade nicht da sind dann passt
einfach mehr hier so in die landschaft
rein und naja was sich bestimmt auch
einige anfragen werden warum ist ja
eigentlich bloß daun
ich kann mir ja schon mal kurz hinsetzen
ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz wie wir das
nun weiter baut werden und zwar hier
kommt wieder ein repeater hinterherkommt
auf stufe 1 und hier kommt auch ein
händler auf stufe 1 und hier zwei
einfach damit hier das ist nachher
dieser redstone den ich wohin davor
gepackt habe der immer aktiviert und
deaktiviert wird hier wieder so ein
diamant raus der nachher aktiviert und
deaktiviert wird und zwar hat kloster
und die tolle eigenschaft ich zeige euch
das mal ganz kurz hier das wenn das hier
hoch geht wird das alles gepaart und der
clown hat die eigenschaft dass ein
signal wenn es von da kommt kann zwar
dahin gehen aber es kann nicht zurück
gehen also dass redstone signal ich
hoffe ich konnte es jetzt ein bisschen
erklären so dass ihr das versteht
na ja also das signal kann hingehen aber
es kann halt nicht zurückgehen und das
ist halt ganz gut dadurch dass dann das
hier aktiviert wird und immer
deaktiviert
also wenn man das an macht kommen da
ganz viele sachen raus weil das hier
anders und ihr seht der kloster und kann
das signal zwar dahin lenken aber nicht
da hin zurück und das hier wird immer
aktiviert und deaktiviert deswegen
kämpfen wir die ganze zeit items raus
und ihr seht doch das ist wenn sie jetzt
jeden moment nichts mehr drin ist und er
ticket einfach weiter rum wenn das mal
ganz kurz ausmachen
das dauert dann immer noch ein bisschen
weil der einfach weiter ich zeige euch
das mal so das ganze ist jetzt aktiviert
wenn man damit aufhört geht am besten
zwar runter aber es macht doch ganz kurz
weiter weil das natürlich immer noch
einen kurzen moment aktiviert ist und
das war es auch eigentlich schon von
diesem tutorial also es sollte
eigentlich auch gar nicht so lange
werden ich das sind bisher zu die ersten
annäherungsversuche von mir in die rats
tontechnik sag ich mal
ich werde einfach noch mal mit den typen
von minecraft pb5 mit denen ich hatte
dropper gemacht habe die hatten gesagt
dass die mir dass eventuell ein bisschen
weiter beibringen damit durch damit ich
euch in zukunft auch redstone tutorials
bieten kann was mich einfach freuen
würde wer übrigens was ich noch sagen
könnte
ich habe den skin von moment warte wie
hieß der prozess habe ich glaub ich
schon im intro gesagt oder ich weiß es
nicht wenn ihr ins kind ist dann
schreibt ihn einfach in die kommentare
wenn ich euren skin anziehen soll
ich würde mich übrigens auch noch über
eine bewertung freuen wenn wir 1000 like
schaffen würde ich mich extrem doll
freuen weil das heißt einfach dass ich
das was ich gerade mache
gefällt euch das ihr weitere red dot
tutorials wollt könnt ihr mir auch mal
die kommentare schreiben
aber ich werde einfach er ein paar
simple einfache tutorials machen die
jeder der auch ein kompletter klug so
wie ich in wetzlar und ist daher dass
auch nachbauen kann und dann würde ich
einfach sagen sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal
ciao